sono stata invitata all'anteprima della
Sirenetta da Disney questo è stato il
momento foto l'evento si è tenuto a
Palazzo Spinola a Milano Qui ci sono io
che già mi sentivo molto a casa appena
arrivata Ho scelto questo abito perché
mi sembrava la giusta via di mezzo tra
Ariel e Ursula e quindi abbiamo un
accenno di Ursula qui ci siamo in salvo
al massimo del nostro romanticismo Ci
sono state delle ballerine che hanno
danzato la doppiatrice di Ursula e la
doppiatrice di Ariel che hanno cantato e
poi è arrivata la sobrissima torta di
Knam che ho assaggiato ed era davvero
molto buona poi ci sono spostati al
cinema per la proiezione io avevo delle
aspettative ovviamente altissime ma devo
dire che il film mi è piaciuto molto E
questa sono io in lacrime alla fine del